feel you're angry you're like making
faces you're upset i make faces all the
time well because you're a woman because
you know i'm not a woman oh i have a
woman sorry oh
get the [ __ ] out of here
thank you we're good we're good so just
some backstory so he was doing a video
where he's going to interviewing people
so he's interviewing these three girls
right does cat calling make you feel
good
sometimes yeah if you're cute you know
what i appreciate them shooting their
shot like why not there's a certain
amount where it's like okay thank you i
appreciate it your mom let me talk to
you like
like what the what the [ __ ] i look like
a dog like oh come here real quick what
like no
that's
so deep
let me talk to you
the way they see their teeth the way
they say they tease let me talk to you
nothing yeah i wasn't even bronxy
i can't do that except for [ __ ] though
here we go how do you respectfully say
you have a fat ass
you've been working out
that sounded creepy
that sounded so creepy hey yo ma you
been working out i see them games though
yeah you got them protein shakes ma
hey
you've been lifting them bump
them dumbbells
yo ma
you run us this [ __ ] right here
nice glutes
cheeks on fleek
i don't like all that personally just be
like oh you're beautiful thank you call
it a
day the fake face yeah she's really
looking upset she's making the biggest
disagreement face i've ever seen
i love that thing
what do you disagree with you don't
think that cat calling can be like a
little enjoyable sometimes
it's not
it's disgusting it's always disgusting
of course
it's never made you feel good no
so what's your opinion on these three
women disagreeing
um
there's a camera in front of them and
they're trying to be in the camera
that's it i think they're being honest
but if you're gonna get it okay i'm
sorry
no
the hostility is fascinating isn't it
women can say one thing another one's
like no no you're oppressed you're just
doing this for the camera you can't even
have your own opinion as a woman no
were you guys being honest it seemed
pretty like a normal response from you
when it gets to like the extreme that's
a problem that's your job
what do you do what's your life what is
this what's going on is this your life
what's going on why are you asking women
questions it's um
excuse me 10 o'clock at night uh why are
you approaching women asking about cat
calling
so we could talk about it and you know
get your perspective why to get your
perspective no no no what is that
benefit for you for me yeah it makes an
interesting video oh really
okay so for what
for what
so you kind of get the idea right no you
just you're just mad you're mad it's fun
it's fine into mine you're mad but you
have to keep it moving so let's go find
out what she's mad about
that's why he does a follow-up video
because this one goes viral the clip of
her you're are you in literally
everything i say and not hear what i'm
saying
so you coming angry and yelling by
calling it mad [ __ ] stupid and
swearing at cursing it's [ __ ] stupid
as [ __ ] and because i'm good at
interviewing i've been doing this for a
while and i'm good at making videos it
goes viral and gets attention and i'm
good at not
immediately
accepting your angry and said i just saw
oh okay you're kind of pretty like let
me just be a normal person that's why
the video does well not because like you
were here helping me out you're
screaming at me trying to make me look
bad that same energy is why guys get
canceled while their platforms get taken
away while they de-platform people you
have a power that you're not really
respecting you think that just because
you're a woman that you have the ability
to yell and be sexist when that's not
the case we should just be respectful
people i'm not a piece of [ __ ] cause i'm
a man i'm not the same man who hurts you
in the past
you said that on video she said no man
has hurt me in the past and i'm just
like
that sounds like kim might have taken
advantage of me if that's what you're
asking that was not what i was asking
she wants to win the argument so bad
she'll change her whole past yeah you'll
be like yeah but you've been single your
whole life no i'm in a relationship
right now [ __ ] you were just saying
that to win this argument now i've been
with my and we get married next year
you're just saying that to win the
argument that's what happened right now
i was drunk as [ __ ] that night that's
wrong
no
no we've been through this already
alcohol is not a factor
it's never a
it's never what you mean it's never a
factor it's not because you're drunked
out complete the sentence whatever it is
whatever it is but it can't influence
you i'm not saying no so it's a factor
that's not listen
they told us when they tell us i didn't
hear this what did they tell you yeah
they told us a bunch of times that you
know if the guy that he's admitted i'll
call his actions it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter you should hold yourself
accountable for what you do so it
doesn't matter if you got alcohol and
you like you say some dumb [ __ ] to a
girl nope you can't blame you can't you
can't go to alcohol you can't use that
card they revoked that card a long ass
time ago really when all the me too
happened they revoked that card yeah
yeah well i think most people would say
there's probably a big difference
between saying a couple things while
you're drunk
and then doing actions they revoked that
card did they and you know what
i agree with you like that there's a
difference between one and the other but
you feel like they don't see that like
no they said even even even saying some
stuff yeah while you're drunk while
you're drunk they revoke that card we
can't use the we can't use the drunk
card being drunk is not okay fine i i
accept but you revoke the card doesn't
mean that you can use it when you want
it no you revoke the card my personal
take is this
if you're drunk
and you start spotting off a bunch of
not racist jokes
but you just start spelling out a bunch
of like
n words or this and m bombs here and all
this other stuff i'ma look at you funny
if you're drunk as a woman and you say
men are the worst they all deserve to
i'm gonna say like you probably
some of that comes from a place of truth
maybe not all of it but you're not
jokingly saying any of it i'm gonna look
at you funny that's me personally go
ahead yeah there's some [ __ ] that every
night solved resolved i was drunk
i think that's a female thing like
saying that you're too drunk and then
you can't you're not responsible you
know i know what the [ __ ] i said uh i
disagree with that men do that all the
time men do that all the time men do
that all the time i i've seen dudes be
at the club drunk and then like say some
gay [ __ ] like like super cake
no no no no no no no no no
like i was like brad what are you doing
right now i was like bro
what the [ __ ] is this and the next day
no that was
that was sus bro i know what the [ __ ] i
said but i'm saying i was drunk and
that's why i had that sauce on my face
it was weird i don't know i didn't
expect that i forgot you guys you even
like i forgot about this whole entire
thing what's your name i'm sico
is that your is that your birth name
okay do do you not share your name
online because my name is hubert but i
like you
what is this this is stupid i was like
yeah this is stupid i mean like it was
weird
what was heard about it asking women
like if they like being tackled and then
in front of the camera where they're
gonna respond and be like oh yeah like i
saw that i saw someone talking what
exactly is weird about that
obviously it's uncomfortable but then
especially no what part like what am i
doing this week filming somebody at late
at night when you're filming women late
at night coming out of bars who are
clearly intoxicated or not intoxicated
i'm not saying everyone was okay first
of all how how would i know that or not
and how do you know i'm not intoxicated
because you're this is your job right
sorry that was rude is it this is your
job you were the only woman who thought
that was weird oh yeah because i i
[ __ ] like have i'm gonna no i'm not
saying anything but i don't give a [ __ ]
about a camera on my face and i'm not
gonna change the way i think because
there's a camera on my face you think
you're all lying what are you saying
then
the more you talk
the more you say the opposite of what
you just said they're not gonna be
honest because they have a camera in the
fridge so they're not honest we're
usually there with the camera in the
face and that's just weird but i'm not
gonna change the way i think or say
anything because there's a camera in my
face well you're special
so you're belittling them
they can't do it you can but they can't
do
girl please you get more
of a response if you're more respectful
then you could have said that no you
weren't being respectful you're the one
that was disrespectful you're the one
who's making the craziest faces and i
don't think it's disrespectful to say
like yo blaze do you guys like cat
calling just like that that he's always
like hey hey ma hey ma hey ma come here
you gotta give me your calling you like
it when i call you like that [ __ ] yeah
you look like you've been working out
yeah yeah how you feel about bumbles
i'm saying bum bells from now on i think
it sounds better
ladies no more dumbbells bum bells you
deserve dumbbells you're smart you're
loyal
you get bum bells
um again you are very respectful i was
thinking that's how i speak that's how i
speak
hey
if you don't get the [ __ ] up out of here
with that [ __ ] that's how i speak i
just speak naturally disrespectful so
that makes it acceptable the other day
all right well you know what i'm
naturally a misogynist how about that
how about that
let's just go like that i'm just this is
not sure to speak you know what i'm
saying like yo women are in fear come on
wake up
y'all trying to tell dudes to be more
respectful when you're calling it's like
nah that's just how i'd be good the
other day i was the other day i was on
the live i was on the live and then we
talked girl
this next girl comes on the live
whatever and are we talking and she's
like what's your side and i roll my eyes
and she's got why you roll her eyes
because that [ __ ] is not true it's
proven not to be true whatever whatever
what not it's it's it's nothing it's a
it's like it's nothing who cares about
astrology it means nothing really yeah i
could have said to you i'm a whole ass
dinosaur it wouldn't mean anything and
she
and said but why you see and she asked
me why do you think it's a lie and i
explained to her well it's been proven
blah blah such and such and listen dummy
and i'm like
oh
no you should have said it's like
who raised you i i did say that though i
did say that yo we didn't we didn't
mummy we dummy no no it's just like oh
no it's just it's just the way i talk
well watch the way you talk cause you
might get decked in the mouth if you
talk like that
ladies get comfortable talking yeah
you talking crazy don't say [ __ ] like
that don't pick and choose with the
sexism you know what i'm saying no i
can't it's a woman and sexism affects me
so why do you think it's acceptable to
film women who may or may not be under
the influence no
what does that have to do with that yes
it does because women's inhibitions are
are down okay i'm not having sex with
them i'm talking it doesn't matter so
you can't even talk to women if they're
drunk now that's right
women by talking to them like they can't
consent to a conversation whoa like
literally like what the [ __ ] are you
saying what are you saying and they were
clearly drunk
no what does that have to do with it
that means that like they probably
wouldn't have the same responses um if
they were sober so what are you implying
that like i'm taking advantage of them
i'm not playing anything all i'm saying
is weird oh
get the [ __ ] out of here
thank you we're good we're good
yes you are it's not because you say i'm
not implying anything that you're
actually not implying anything okay
that's not how this whole [ __ ] works
part of it now you think it's stupid but
you've just contributed to it it's
stupid you can you can contribute to
something that's stupid it doesn't
matter i don't know i don't even know
what was happening there i wouldn't look
at me as my sauce i know what's
happening here well i'm drunk you can't
contribute you could contribute
something stupid you're just disagreeing
with everything i'm saying because you
don't like me
because you want to have control over
the situation not like i can't not like
somebody that i do not know
you are the coolest part about this
whole video is you say i'm drunk i'm
drunk i'm drunk can anybody detect the
difference in their behavior between her
being drunk and sober
you know what this is like
new year new me a year later still the
same [ __ ] weight [ __ ] nothing
changed
you didn't hit the gym once
you just made an announcement i'm drunk
it's a new year uh sorry stupid
it's the same [ __ ]
is it not the same [ __ ] it's the same
[ __ ]
i don't know i was just preserving me
i'm trying boo boo you look identical to
everybody just as hostile
rough the identical just the lighting is
different crazy lack of self-awareness
man when you don't like me like a man
coming up at night you're ready to
automatically just no disagree no no no
no no you're contributing something
stupid it doesn't matter you're just
saying loud stuff the first thing that
comes to your head it doesn't have any
reasoning or logic behind it
yes it does anyone could contribute to
anything stupid it doesn't have to you
don't it doesn't nam you can contribute
to something simply something stupid
stop talking
and i know what this is
all right i think i'm good with this oh
no keep on going we i just wanted to
finish her point just to a point i just
want to finish what her point and it
will where she was going with this [ __ ]
and what his response is and after that
girl you know
he's going to say like
turn into a jeremiah song let's go
you've been without even knowing it's
stupid without even and and you can look
back in hindsight and be like oh yeah
that was [ __ ] stupid you can
contribute contribute to anything
without even realizing what you're
contributing to
well you weren't looking at it with
logic and reasoning you're looking at it
from a place of emotion
you're you're going with what you feel
you're angry you're like making faces
you're upset i make faces all the time
well because you're a woman because you
know i'm not a woman um i am a woman
sorry
no no see how
bro shut the [ __ ] up
i mean okay that's the thing
shut up
you know what i'm gonna say this i don't
argue it's a waste of time sometimes
having conversations with people it's
not a yes if the person's not responding
what you're saying they're just like
waiting to get their time to point it
shut up just
it would have been it would have been
nice if you would have shut up it would
have been nice if you would shut up and
listen cause you're not listening
nothing right now you're really in
i gotta even if you say you don't even
if you say it's not an argument the
whole way you go about this is so you
can say all you want no it's not an
argument it's not an argument it's not
an argument no it's not no it's not no
it's not no no no it is i make faces all
the
time
shut up that's something yay pipe down
we all need to shut up at some point go
ahead yeah i'll just say
i'll just say this if there's anything
you guys can take away from this is
learn to walk away some conversations
are not worth having
some things do not need your energy some
things don't need your time the same way
i'm walking away from the rest of this
video because it's a waste of my time
you also walk away from anybody who
talks to you like this and walk away
early okay
conserve whatever energy because the
more that you try to invest in this the
more frustration you feel the more
you're going to get zapped oh this is a
[ __ ] vampire bro yep it's a vampire
waste of time
let's have a card
and every time you turn into a [ __ ]
flintstone looking like tanzanian devil
when you speak shut up
take a second
reflect on what the person said and then
respond
there's nothing wrong with taking a
pause
but just feel like no there's a point
there's a point think about what it is
that's coming out of your mouth calm
down jesus [ __ ] christ
just calm down
it's like
none of this
none of us